welcome back to new rock stars my name
is mt and who are the eternals like no
seriously who are the eternals from the
marvel comics anyway the nerd word on
the street is that chloe zhao has
brought the wow the kind of wow that i
need to see right now in the new
eternals movie that she just whipped up
for marvel studios due out really soon
in november after all so who the hell
are these eternals anyway and how the
hell do they factor into the overall
marvel universe well wonder no more my
curious nerd babies because your nerd
daddy t has got the full load down on
just who these powerful unnecessarily
beautiful young gods are so buckle up
gang because we going back in time
because of course we can talk about the
eternals without referencing the nba
all-stars that are the celestials these
tall-ass cosmic science nerds are in
fact a reason for the season because
millions of years ago during the point
in human evolution where the
evolutionary line between apes and
humans started to emerge the celestials
must have saw it trending on twitter
because they quickly arrived on earth
just to see what all this monkey
business was all about and after
examining their ape-ass genes the
celestials were like that's good
that's damn good because they saw our
genetic potential to become more and so
because of this these cosmic chrome
domes corralled a couple of clueless
cavemen and created three branches of
humanity from the genes of homo erectus
man the basic [ __ ] humans that's us we
the basic [ __ ] 100 ugly-ass mutating
deviants and 100 genetically perfect
eternals but hey don't worry the basic
[ __ ] humans did not leave empty-handed
because this is where the celestials
installed the x-gene within their terran
livestock to sit and wait until
humanity's evolution was ready to see a
small alcoholic canadian stab people
with his bones and also when they gave
marvel humans the ability to become
superheroes instead of super death
statistics when hit with things like
cosmic rays gamma rays fighter rays
woman rays man rays all kinds of rays
really but anyways because the
celestials put this amazing genetic
potential within us regular reginalds
they still needed someone to babysit us
right i mean space nerd science is not
going to do itself and humanity did
almost get wiped out by milk crates a
couple of weeks ago so yeah uh we
definitely need some eternals because
the main function of the eternals like
the very reason why they exist is to
make sure that human evolution goes on
without interruption especially
interruption from the devious deviant
branch of humanity because those other
waffles always be scheming with a plot
to make it to the top but they're always
in the middle because they always
getting caught by icarus and his
immortal friends fighting deviants from
the shadows from their home base of
olympia where the eternals were
sometimes mistaken for greek gods
fighting demons and trolls though
olympia is located in greece in the
comics in the movies it seems that
olympia is an entire planet where these
eternals come from so the origins are a
little bit different in the mcu but
their general purpose remains the same
to control the deviant population
however the eternals weren't always so
efficient in their deviant controlling
ways you know despite the eternals being
gifted immortality super strength a
regenerative healing factor and the
ability to manipulate vast cosmic energy
in different ways different ways like
you know icarus flight cosmic hand blast
and laser vision bakari super speed
cersei's matter transmutation sprites
master illusions vastos's cosmic weapon
energy projection druid's telepathic and
empathic manipulation abilities vena's
energy weapons gilgamesh's elite energy
armoring slash defense and kingo's
warrior-like reflexes and endurance and
ajax extremely crucial power of
celestial speech and communication
because good god when the celestial
speak we better be listening or else
we're all gonna die and thanks to
skillshare for sponsoring this video
skillshare is an online learning
community with thousands of expiring
classes for creators explore new skills
deepen existing passions and just get
lost in creativity skillshare offers
classes designed for real life learn and
grow with short classes that fit any
schedule and each class is a combination
of video lessons and a class project and
it's curated specifically for learning
meaning that there are no ads and
they're always launching new premium
classes and skillshare's entire catalog
of classes now offers subtitles in
spanish french portuguese and dutch and
they have classes and topics that new
rockstars fans will enjoy like animation
film music and freelancing and one of
their classes that looks really cool is
productivity for creatives build a
system that brings out your best by
thomas frank he's a prolific musician
and content creator and his class goes
over stuff like how to set up your
physical and digital space to work for
you not against you the first 1000 of
our subscribers to click the link in the
description will get a one month free
trial of skillshare so that you can
start exploring your creativity today
despite all of that really cool [ __ ] the
one thing that the eternals could not do
was reproduce amongst themselves thanos
and his brother star fox from the super
smash brothers series were one of the
few exceptions to this because their
mother sui-san used the quantum bands
while she was giving birth to them so
it's very rare but the deviants on the
other hand were given the powers of
grossly accelerated genetic mutation and
breeding ability the deviants be
and because of this their physical
technological and societal evolution
accelerated at a breakneck pace like
eventually causing them to take over
most of the planet and enslave humanity
by the year 18000 bc through their
massive deviant kingdom of lemaria
despite the best efforts of the eternals
who were protecting humanity from the
shadows however since controlling the
deviants was literally the one job the
celestials gave the eternals before they
left the first time when the celestials
came back a second time those boys were
pissed they were pissed off so pissed
that they decimated the entire surface
of the planet in an event called the
great cataclysm and then told the
eternals to get their [ __ ] together or
else they were just gonna blow up the
whole thing and nobody gets an earth but
okay
why though if the eternals are made to
control the deviant population why in
angelina jolie's holy name do the
celestials keep making them on multiple
planets like as we've already seen with
the squirrels like the entire squirrel
race is what happens when deviants take
over the base species like every scroll
you see is a deviant well it all has to
do with energy specifically life energy
because the celestials have a dark
counterpart in this universe a dark
ancient race of evil space bugs called
the horde yes i am aware that in a
previous video i did say that the
aspirins were the dark counterpart of
the celestials but the aspirants are the
dark multiversal counterpart whereas the
horde are the celestials in universe
counterpart while the celestials were
all about seeding and evolving life the
horde infestation is all about
destroying that life both the celestials
and the horde live in service to this
all-powerful being called the fulcrum
who was essentially jack kirby because
here's the deal every planet is just one
big life energy farm and all of that
life energy is supposed to go directly
to the fulcrum at the very end of that
planet's life or the end of the
celestial's experimentations when the
celestials come to a planet for their
final inspection if there are more
humans than deviants on the planet the
fulcrum awards that planets total life
force to the celestial team to create
more life however if there are more
deviants on the planet than the fulcrum
gives all of that life energy to the
horde to cause more universal
destruction it's sort of like the matrix
in a weird way because we are
technically being used as batteries and
this much like galactus is just one of
the ways the marvel universe maintains
life force balance and could be what
ajax was referring to when she mentions
the life energies of earth triggering
the emergence because we do know this
movie is going to be all about the life
energy of the planet and maybe just
maybe the horde could come into play in
the mcu's future possibly as the mcu
version of the annihilation wave if
you're gonna do bugs you might as well
just merge the two concepts together
same that is the eternal's origins
explained in a super condensed nutshell
what do you guys think do you think that
we could be getting the horde in the
future let us know in the comment
section below my nerd babies but thank
you guys so much for watching this video
please be sure to hit up new
rockstarsmerch.com to find cool new
shirts and stuff from your favorite
nerdums like venom what if all that
stuff on newrockstarsmerch.com but of
course you can follow me at
mastertainment if you want to see me
tweet some weird [ __ ] but most
importantly follow new rockstars on
twitter and youtube wherever we are if
you do on youtube make sure to hit that
notification bell if you get
notifications whenever we upload a video
thank you guys so much for watching i
love you guys so much and i will see you
guys later goodbye
[Music]
you